[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i can't give you away too much
yeah
i'm walking through uh the town and i
have my
case and i'm making my way downtown yeah
walking fast faces passing i'm homebound
okay terry crews yeah i know yeah i did
that
but i sounded better yeah you sounded
better absolutely
that's his funniest role ever hilarious
nah bro
you don't like him on uh everybody ace
chris he's good hilarious
he's so oh
[Applause]
yeah joey diaz yeah he gives diaz a
cheeseburger yeah he said you're gonna
need that
he's like yeah he's like i'm still on
the team
i love that movie that's a great i've
never seen the original but i love that
original
reynolds yeah that's the right as good
as that one no it's not that's why burt
reynolds in it though
at the end yeah because he's the
original he played that sailor yeah he
died
you're seeing when he slaps that
reporter no
he's out like a red carpet report asks
him something he doesn't like he slaps
him just
really yeah it's great will smith slaps
a reporter too really yeah but that guy
was trying to kiss him
yes he tried to go in for a kiss oh yeah
he smacked him and will smack but it was
a soft smack
i know that guy's known for that though
he tries to kiss a bunch of people he
didn't
uh he almost got arrested because he
grabbed gigi hadid from behind like
randomly
oh really he was the same guy that tried
to grab him right
huh he tried to try kim yeah the [ __ ] up
oh yeah here he is right here nipsey
slapped a reporter
oh yeah no he slapped the security guard
at the beach
especially since we're going oh my god
[Applause]
yeah i need another angle yeah he comes
in hot
he's trying to like tank his uh young
burst is a is for sure
an alien so we're trying to find him out
here tonight this this film
is those red carpets are so weird
this video kind of sucks oh [ __ ] that
yeah and so
[Music]
probably start laughing all right rachel
you approached her last phone i would
start laughing
if that reporter said it was like oh my
god bring the show i started laughing
i mean he went landed yeah i turned my
cheek
whoo but he still get that cheek he gets
something i started laughing yeah i
wouldn't be too mad
yeah you wanna be too mad you won't be
too mad if they put their hands on you
that's the brand whatever they want to
do dog
hell no i don't know if i could i'd be
like hey dog
that's probably just his quick reaction
just initial natural reaction he thought
about it
he's from fears from philly yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah
i love will smith oh i love will smith
who doesn't i think he's great
he he uh that pursuit of happiness
oh that one's good [ __ ] me you guys
can't wait to have kids now i won't
watch it oh
what about when they're in the uh in the
background the bathroom
oh my god yeah because someone's trying
to break
trying to get in the movie so yeah it's
so sad
so don't let anyone tell you everyone
here a little tanner
everyone a little tanner from
neighborhoods yeah
i mean yeah we was walking we were the
three
most colored guys in naples yeah for
those who don't know naples is the
average age of 65.
keep going and they've rich rich rich
you know
i love real estate so every city we got
to always look at the houses
i didn't realize naples enabled that
different level what was that
it was 10 mil 50 15 million 50.
50. oh 50. one was 49 million dollars
49.99 and you said it wasn't anything
you know that one was a man that was a
man those ones you were pointing out
were in a match okay
he's like damn these are mansion like
these are not mansions it looks so
mansion
yeah it's uh eight thousand yeah what do
we figure out it's eight thousand square
feet or bigger
and even eight thousand square feet
considered a mini mansion these days a
mini mansion
two that's right don't hurt them naples
was dope though right
yeah i would say my favorite uh city in
florida
they were good by far though well the
crowds were great i'm saying city in
general oh city in general yeah
yeah cause you know it was very chill
very relaxed it wasn't like uh
we went to miami miami was like lit
south beach yeah
south beach's chaos yeah south south
beach was chaos it's cool
even for like just regular brunch it's
like hey too south beach is a lot that's
a lot staples
like yeah eating breakfast sandwiches
even i was called the n-word
yeah nipples yeah yeah someone shot it
out i was like
[Laughter]
my guy or black guy oh there's no black
there's a yeah we were oh we literally
why would a blind guy go man
no he's just i don't know just like a
colloquial way
i'm saying rich white like bentley's
lamb
royals royce's just it was just like oh
yeah the security guards
we're walking to the beach a white guy
told brittany hey you know these dorky's
no that's why he didn't say that no he
said they with you
they're with you huh the only thing we
like dark ground heroes are birds
the wildlife out there so we stayed on
like our our house was on the uh the
dock so the waters behind us
the [ __ ] wildlife lizards up the
[ __ ] oh yeah did you see that
go to my program what a book so i found
this photo oh yeah that's a rush no
eric's line
that's a [ __ ] i know roaches that was a
[ __ ] roach
i found this roach in my [ __ ] bedroom
yep right there
i like cocaine on them too
so let's go to the next video then i go
to put it outside the lizard oh
no we're like what the [ __ ] we got a
lizard
that's dope and then every time we walk
in the house the lizards just be like
getting more than oh yeah they were
ready
that's so crazy how quick they like you
literally just dropped it
someone must be i mean there must be a
thing like like the owners must
just catch roaches because how would
they be conditioned to do that
yeah you were trying to be nice you were
trying to just set the fella free yeah i
was like oh jay was like
kill that thing like nah man let him
live lizard said
i don't think so yeah they said i know
i'm gonna do i know what i'm doing
but wait for it there's a picture of us
on the beach there chen we were uh
we were the youngest on the beach by 70
years i would say
yep we even took a picture white boy
summer
coach
yeah youngest squad in naples by 30 yeah
we were
oh oh i didn't i just i sent the one
with the uh the old dude
yeah i'll do one in the picture yeah i
got it tits on him he did have i'll say
this he was cool though
he was so old someone was there getting
the picture yeah like all right everyone
kept going you were you boys football
players
that caused you rugby players yeah they
thought we were rugby rugby players i
was like what it was chill out there and
then our boy eric made the goddamn trip
because he has this restaurant out there
go to this restaurant jen
you ever fall in love with a man yeah
man this guy
was just the heart and soul of naples
virginia underscore naples virgina
virginia underscore so it's authentic
mediterranean food bro we would go there
every night after the show
he would roll out the trucatery board
i was doing i was doing hookah i was
doing hookah every night
he got that wagu bee for us oh yeah
tell
no it wasn't that plate
yeah everything on that menu was fired
for that
gelato salmon the potatoes oh my gosh
bro we was lit oh that's oh that's that
bartender
that's parked on uh bartenders that's a
chatty oh my god
that bartender you would ask late at
night it's
10 a.m because like people knew you know
they knew us and then he would come in
like so what's going on here man hey
how'd you guys get started in comedy
yeah bro
i just did two hours on stage we're not
doing this right now
but all right you guys need a drink
right no we're not now we're good i can
make you drink you're like seriously
name something i'll main feature drink
right i'm not drinking dude
come on give me a drink if you don't get
the [ __ ] out of here you saw him
he saw brendan smoking hookah he was
like oh that we call that a cleveland
no no chicago yeah you know what that is
like what something what did he say it
dude you've never seen more chocolate
wasted white girls in your life man
just old like elderly cougars hammer
hammers like
one one wife they had to kick out
because her husband was dancing with
another girl
yeah and she would not leave oh she's
trying to throw [ __ ] at her yeah she
went but
she went behind the bar and was staring
at him like mm-hmm i thought she was
crazy but she made the most sense
no i didn't think she was crazy she well
they were like god this lady's crazy i'm
like damn what's going on like her
husband's in there dancing another trick
i'm like
well yeah
ufc 261 is this weekend
saturday night mazwell usman rematch
it's going
down you also got shevchenko uh
you also got weilei zhang verse frickin
rose three title fights this card is
stacked
watch the card with your buddies and
then make bank with draftking sportsbook
and they're also got this special
giveaway for you 26-1
odds on either title contender to reign
victorious
that's right pick either main event
fighter camaro usman or mazdal
and if they win this weekend's ufc 261
title
the draftking sports book will give you
26 to 1 odds
just bet 5 on either fighter to win and
if they walk out with the belt you can
cash 130 dollars
or if you're feeling real frosty my
freaking parlay pick you gotta
take usman wayleigh zhang and uriah
faber
and uh i'm sorry ryan hall you're right
chin good catch
dude so yeah pick camaro who's been
whaley zhang and uriah hall if all three
of them win
they boost your odds so you make a ton
of bank dude
so all three have to win in order to win
that so go and put your mma knowledge to
the test
with draftking sportsbook all right
draftkings is safe secure reliable so
you can deposit withdraw your funds
whenever you want
download top rated draftking sportsbook
app now use the promo code fighter when
you sign up to turn
five dollars into 130 if the title
contender of your choice wins place your
bet
and watch the fists fly this weekend
that's code fighter to turn five dollars
and 130
dollars if the fighter of your choosing
takes home the crown
for limited time only a draftking sports
book must be 21 and older new jersey
west virginia or pennsylvania only
new customers only restrict supply c
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler again
that's
draftking sportsbook promo code fighter
yo man
mother's day is coming up maybe girl's
birthday maybe your mama's birthday
whatever it is
you want to give him something nice and
that's why bluenile.com
came on in you can celebrate all of
life's special moments
from creating a custom engagement ring
of her dreams huh
huh to gift a once-in-a-lifetime special
piece at all prices you won't find a
traditional
jeweler all right bluenile.com you
can focus on fine jewelry man we're
talking diamond jewelry
cocktail rings tennis bracelets gold
layering jewelry jewelry is typically
given as a gift
specifically focused on mother's day
gifting maybe it's your wife girlfriend
mom mother-in-law grandmother whatever
it is
you gotta get on it with blue nile all
right make mother's day something
special
all right celebrate those special women
your life with blue
nile and listen you can trust blue now
blue now is different from their
competitors they don't mark up to mark
down meaning bluenow.com's everyday
price are competitive to other online
retail
retailers all right they have expert
advice 24 7 legendary service with 30
day returns all right
not perfect not the gift that she wanted
cool 100 satisfaction guarantee shop
stress free
with guaranteed free shipping returns
this mother's day give mom something she
will treasure forever
with jewelry from blue now.com and the
fire and the kids listeners get 50
off your purchase over 500 this is only
for you guys all right
so use code fighter that's code fighter
plus every order is insured ships free
arrives in discrete little package
doesn't give away the surprise shop
stress free on bluenow.com today
that place is great eric made the trip
man yeah shout out
shout out to eric that's our boy yeah
that bartender tuck your ear off
yeah he'll talk to europe he is a
bartenders bartender usually pretty
chatty cathy you know they have the
locals
we were out there but we were outside
though he'd come to our table
and be like so what's going on over here
yeah he was just standing there
with his hands on his hips just smiling
yeah i had my reservations about going
to naples and especially doing off the
hook comedy but here's the problems like
all my friends have been doing comedy
for like
20 30 years so off the comedy i'm sure
years ago five to ten years ago was a
restaurant
slash comedy club so it wasn't ran like
it is now now it's a straight-up
straight-up comedy venue they have a new
manager and they bring
you know ron white's there next week
they got [ __ ] you know big comics
there
but um so you hear these horror stories
about it and i i
that place was dope it was really fun
that was dope
i like the stage set up i love the
stations yeah it was like very
like the low ceiling i would 100 percent
go back i was lit yeah
that place was really dope yeah theo
goes dude i did it 15 years ago and
the guy who owns his name is captain
brian again i thought he's gonna be
dressed like a
grown man in a captain's uniform not at
all dressed like a real player
and he also uh back in the day he feels
that they
used to make him dress up as sailors oh
that's kangar
yeah that's ken theo said he would make
him wear a sailor hat on stage
are you serious all the comics would you
do it no
hard passed on harvest on the sailor's
hat there's there's
malik oh that's us right there oh
look at it all right look at chappelle
look it's skinny
i know i really don't know you look
slimmer i saw your story today with
uh mark and you look a lot slimmer why
thank you
i'm trying my best yeah but that video
how they set it up is so great
i think they just had a good angle you
look slimmer but you look you put on
muscle for sure yeah you look nice i
don't know what you weigh i don't know
if you lost weight you probably put on
pounds from the mic no who cares about
but the muscle
but i got those muscle weights more than
fat i got a scale in a trunk now
you don't want to weigh yourself i don't
want to win especially otherwise i would
just get
discouraged no i should break your heart
yeah it'll break my heart
i just know i don't look like that
before picture okay yeah that's
something i know that i know that that's
all that matters
yeah i ain't trying to look like that no
you look i worked out over the weekend
too you know i was going to the gym
i'm impressed dude i mean i could i
wanted to go with you got to
[ __ ] work oh yeah yeah yeah you got
to work but like that the gym is funny
it's one of those uh plant fitness
yeah they i'd rather slip my throat they
go there's no lunking
monkeying yeah it's like it's a term
that they use where it's like no
like no judgment like no uh you can't
like
you can't like dead lift you can't like
squat you can't do any of that you can't
wear a sleeve or something yeah you
can't because they don't want that the
market
they don't want like big guys yeah they
don't want people coming they want
that's why
that's why that's my free pizza every
friday i was like brendan won't come to
this gym
no because if yeah if you like put down
a weight
like heavy i think there's an alarm that
goes off no
way you have it yeah oh yeah oh so here
it is yeah
what does it say and longest you pursue
grunts drops rates and judges
oh no no i get this uh describes lunk as
a person who
works out hard is dedicated lifts heavy
weights
and has the lunk alarm to alert people
the presence of a lung yes i'm a [ __ ]
loved planet but it's like no i mean oh
i'm sorry i left
heavy weight i'm sorry i'm trying to get
stronger planet fitness
like i don't think i don't think anyone
that lives heavy is judging another
person because they're not listening
is planet fitness ran by north korea i
can't
wear a sleeveless shirt is governor
is gavin newsom the owner of this
[ __ ] place he says oh the alarm also
alerts gym managers
to the lungs throw me out dog this is a
local hunk is a racial slur dog
i'm saying fitness is like i'm saying
this is like a big person's safety
nice dog i'll tell you who needs planets
dude i'll tell you who needs planet
fitness
on the flight on the flight from florida
to california jay you know jay books on
[ __ ] jay booked this the emergency row
he was long flight i'm going to get some
instruments all right cool man
and he goes we both sit down he's like
he's like the reason i picked there's no
one in the middle spot this is going to
be dope we have all this room like hell
yeah
and they looked at his phone he was ah
[ __ ] someone booked the middle seat oh
man
hopefully somebody's small coming on
whole plane is seated we're waiting
waiting
i'm not even trying to be mean
a 400 pound woman gets on the plane i'm
like
no dude she can't get through the aisles
she's like trying to do like the
the elephant shuffle like guys like this
she's just knocking all the things down
like oh
no jay's like get your mind right man
she said she just plops down
dude i'm talking
it was just i'm getting away from the
wall i'm like oh no the for [ __ ] five
hours i'm like this it was
insane dude you had to stand up a little
bit i went
to the back of the plane for an hour and
stood my hip was
i mean i was squished against the wall
hanging out with the students i don't
have a problem with big people do your
thing
probably should buy two seats though if
you're over four honda i thought that's
what
i don't i don't know what the rules are
it's probably fat shame because they
probably can't enforce it
oh how about she go we're sitting there
we're sweating she's just sweating like
literally has me and jane headlock she's
sweat the only way she could sit has me
and jane headlocks like this
headlight friday afternoon yeah
terry crews there yeah she's sweating
sweating she goes man we're packed in
here like sardines am i right
i was like you ain't a sardine
there's two sardines here there's two
sardines
sardines there's two sardines and
there's a
grouper in the middle yeah didn't you
lay it didn't you lean on her a little
bit i fell asleep on her fat ass tricep
that's a good spot yeah it was nice it
was probably comfortable but my mask
came down and then the stewardess woke
me up sir
mask i'm like [ __ ] oh because then
you're up yeah you have a loose mess
yeah you should be fine i like to
breathe man but hey man you got through
the flight
yeah you did barely my hips man oh yeah
bro look because i was sitting right
behind him and i was uh
i lean over and talk to jay and jay had
his phone watching tv like this i look
at brennan
brittany's leaning forward like looking
at a podcast and stuff like that and
his shoulder you can't even see brendan
you just see a head he's just like
yeah he's like i couldn't sit back he
couldn't say bad guys she was
shoot she was friendly though she was
good yeah she kept going man when they
bring these snacks i was like
i don't know i don't know man i don't
know
but you know when it's hot and you're
like been flying all day you just kept
going when they bring the snacks like i
don't ask them
i don't know i don't know do you think
you need these snacks
dude should you and me be eating the
snacks you think
by the way why would they why would she
book the emergency room that's an
emergency oh that's a good point too
just just from a straight up physicality
yeah i was hey i was ready
oh you know what she got on so late they
didn't see her when they go
are you capable and willing if there's
an emergency oh that's what i'm saying
so she skipped all that probably on
purpose
oh yeah cause i i would assume that's a
liability because we had an open seat
behind oh dude we're all going down
i couldn't get out you can like if you
want me to play [ __ ]
hero you know hero and nope no i can't
get out i'm stuck
there's only one side right it's that
emergency dude i got i stood in the back
of the plane for an hour
i know damn i saw you i was like oh how
about that car show
what car show remember jay shot bullied
us and go in the car show yeah
but here's the thing but it was as it
was car guy listen i'm a car guy jay's a
car
guy yeah jay goes yo we got to go this
rev
the rap dude dude go the rev institute
jen
did this caught so it was it's the most
valuable
private collection of cars in the world
they're
the cars over there at least over a
billion dollars in cars like they have
the first 911
r ever the first ferrari ever the first
lamborghini ever
they have cars that complete le mans
they have like all the poor
every it's a big porsche place like yeah
jay leno stores his cars there
uh adam carolla stows the storage scars
there cleveland john
yeah no wyclef john sold them his
mclaren where he [ __ ] up because he
bought it in i think 95
if you would have held on to it that
thing's worth 30 30 million 30 million
gold in the back of the uh trump bro
how about malik oh this caught so i
asked so
he can't be around mclaren's no you
can't be around nice [ __ ]
there's no idea hack dude who's the guy
who shoots dave's the tour do you
remember
pedro pedro shout out to pedro yeah he's
the main mechanic there he's like a big
fan that's how we got it
cool he's showing us all the private
[ __ ] and then he was like uh i'm not
supposed to talk about pricing on cars
he's about to tell you i'm like yeah
that's what i want to know dude
so we go to this car i forget what car
it was
it was a mclaren not even the making
land there's another one you that i was
like oh my god
i forget what it was but it was like
from 1938 and i go how much this car he
goes
he goes dude he's like i'm not even
being facetious there he goes
we there's no price on it like we got
offered a hundred million dollars
and we wouldn't sell it you know so the
it's like there
it's priceless like if maybe 500 million
he was i don't know it's priceless and i
was like damn that's crazy
i'm talking to him i looked over malik's
in the car
grabbing the thing going like this no is
this the emergency brake i was like oh
yeah and i i didn't want him to see i
didn't want him to see him like yeah i'm
like hey what's that over there he's
like oh i just went over that
this cap 500 million
especially the f1 mclaren from 95 is
built in the back
because the the way the exhaust exhaust
is set up
when they were going through pre-trials
and kind of a picture of it it would get
so hot it would burn the outside of the
car
so they had to cover in real 24 karat
gold
so the back has all this gold all over
it he's talking me i like him
he has because they don't own that car
he has like literally you know the white
mickey mouse gloves on like the usher's
use
he's talking to me i look over matt this
is the car that's all the gold that goes
that's just real gold i did do that oh
my god
listen for one he lifted i'm right here
chilling right you know what it is
you're a little too comfortable no no
it's not what do you mean you're too
comfortable
because we have like this vip like you
show us right you got too comfortable
what would you do if you scratched that
car what are you going to do what are
you going to do
30 million dollars what the [ __ ] would
we do malik you ever think about that
i didn't think about that but again i'll
this is why you're
the problems you're having with your
sentra now think of the problems
you would have with the mclaren f1 and
there's there i think there's only 50 of
them or some 30.
he said the 20s it's nuts that's one of
them
and you took your filthy hands
he had to put gloves on yeah dude that's
the car
and in the back you see him with the
gloves on yeah shout out to pedro
shout out to pedro he was great he was
all the [ __ ] he knew
yeah so that that car that was why
cliffs yeah
i don't think i can roll in that kind of
car though you could no
i don't like because it's got seats for
them
you're in the middle two small girls put
them up
oh you pull up in that thing bro some of
them cars i was like
y'all love them but y'all can't fit
inside them that's why i was looking i
was like how are you all
those they're those smaller races well
porsches originally were smaller but
yeah a lot of them like uh isn't it like
a weight for racing that's f1 cars they
gotta make weight
what's uh [ __ ] f1 racing they had a f1
car what's the f1
f1 is the type of racing they're real
those cockpits real small
it was the wheels that's the guys
yeah he could say come on you gotta let
me get in the picture
he did something like that he did it
come on you gotta let me get it you know
this thing goes viral you guys know why
that's what he said is it damn doggy
viral i know
meanwhile he's worth 300 million i know
probably yeah i mean
nuts nuts that water was nice
oh it was so salty oh great we took it
to we dipped our face in there uh
but how about brendan go in there do
like six headstands
like being a kid hey his handstand is
better than your back flip oh yeah
what bro go to my ig his back flip was
[ __ ]
the backflip on the trampoline oh yeah
the sonic one
bruh well again now i did i did like
i literally did because you were jumping
i was like oh he's got he's gonna get
some air well you didn't catch the one
when i really like my legs got tired no
i was there
no no we were there okay good that's
right
how about brennan jump in here he didn't
do a flip very good
[Music]
i was a good one though right that was
good oh my god
i lost my balance on the second one
though but that's a legitimate
that's a legit flip on the first one my
next it looks so fun
either way i would call it more of a
somersault than a
flip personality yeah cause you didn't
you're just rolling yeah no on that
first
one i caught air all your are you all
your uh cheerleading boys
were there oh yeah they were like was he
serious i go yeah
he's 100 serious because they thought
you were joking i go no he
that's that's backflips that's him
because
probably the same size then if you got
bigger legs yeah naples was dope yeah
naples is great
i don't know i had a blast there i like
yeah austin this weekend man
going back keep austin thick yep mark
harley's coming
our trainer's coming mark harley yeah
keep you all right keep you all tight
long hair lying
do you think he's gonna judge us if we
bad on after this yeah yeah
good though like we eat all day and then
uh we didn't eat a lot but when we did
eat it wasn't great yeah
my body doesn't do well in neighborhoods
i think it was just the the those let
that last
like when we go to the restaurant well i
mean i don't know what we do
we don't even know what he just brings
the food out everything yeah he's so
funny because what the [ __ ] i
i got you guys don't [ __ ] bring it
out he's like cigars you like cigars
he was to um get the [ __ ] out of here
all right dude he's so new york new york
he's like michael rapport of restaurant
owners
yeah yeah i'm like dude you don't have
to keep doing this like i can pay you
your money get the [ __ ] out of it yeah
oh but he beats sophie
he came up to me after the show and he
was like come to my [ __ ] restaurant
i'll hook you guys up i'll do whatever
you like i [ __ ] got you just come to
the front which we get offered all this
yeah
he was so aggressive about it i was like
i don't know if we're gonna [ __ ] like
six minutes from it yeah it looks good
like you know
we looked it up online yeah we stayed
committed but he was so
like a lot more chill oh he gave us an
ipad we were able to watch the ben
askren jake paul
fight the restaurant yeah yeah he
treated us good
no he's great man that's my boy i keep
thinking about that gelato bro
no dude [ __ ] all that that is the best
steak i've ever had i do beef
oh so we're not going to talk about the
sea bass the best sea bass i had in my
life tim you would have loved it oh
whatever
did you like sea bass it's one of my
favorite fish ever it was chilling
yeah this was chilling chili and sea
bass it's so good it's like that white
flaky fat fish yeah it's fat
it's fatty fat yeah good fat how big is
the sea bass is it big yeah they're big
they look ugly too you wouldn't want to
eat it if you saw it let me see how cute
it is
no far far left look at him that's our
bun that's our guy right there
he looks like he could be jeff bezos his
younger brother
he probably in that monday i know he was
so cool though
he's kind of my [ __ ] restaurant yeah
i'll [ __ ] take care of you
i can't do a new york accent but that's
that ooh
what that fish looks like that's what it
looked like super ugly i didn't know
they look like yeah they're disgusting
looking but they taste amazing what does
the grouper look like ooh they're ugly
oh for real
my grandma has lips like a grouper
oh god damn you're
alive my grandma looks like that
[ __ ] you didn't have to out her like
that yeah here's what it is
man hey that's where i get my lips from
hey how lit were we watching uh
60 days was it six months that's 60 days
in we always find a show to watch on the
road and that's the only week
it was 60 days in six years that would
run through all the season
great i loved it you've never seen it
before no i've only seen clip because
they'll post like uh
clips i've seen every trailer clips on
uh
youtube i've seen every season i was
watching the arizona one
yeah when they were in arizona and some
of them like become like
gangsters some some some take over yeah
you gotta get them out
they get two into it oh the one dude
well you definitely sees him i think he
was season three
season three no it's been out for a hot
second but season three the dude
he completes the 60 days and kicks ass
he's like it's actually pretty easy man
like
this ain't that bad and they're like you
wanna do another six he's like sure does
another 60. he's like
ah this is actually i don't mind it man
i'll do another 60.
and his fiancee's like what the [ __ ]
dude i found out he committed suicide
dude
he got out and committed suicide damn he
was just volunteering that's him right
there
yeah you voluntarily nate burl that's
him right here he's a beast with him man
wow oh he handled it well yeah oh dude
he everyone loved him he was like
helping everybody out there'd be a fight
he'd talk him out of it
he's like he's like i feel like i'm
doing good work and then you want to do
another 60. he's like hell yeah this is
easy
oh i mean look i mean come on
gun shock you know this isn't a mission
of guild i'm just tired i've been
through so much of my life the pain
of my situation now hurts more than ever
i imagine i can't keep going on
that's dark oh i think he had a kid on
the way too damn it
criminal the uh the puerto rican dude he
like he
earned his stripes real quick well he
was in like teens before
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah he was getting on
my nerves a little bit though really bro
he was running [ __ ]
he's getting on my nerves and then the
other little black little black dude the
black dude that was a cop but then jay
and i was like
i don't care jay and i was like yo why
don't you just fight that big black guy
who j was
like he was this guy was chiseled big
black guy didn't want to be on the show
right yes he didn't
probably because he was he was easy yeah
i was like he should be the gang leader
hey what happened he's turning on the ac
it's just as hot as [ __ ]
we were i'm not even trying to be funny
we were naple threes
we didn't get one oh yeah at least mal
could get looked
no no i was with the crew no one looked
at me nothing
are you guys maple threes because
everyone there is good looking or are
you naple threes
because it's nice we don't look like we
drive
uh bentley finley's yeah
the older gentleman is the vibe there
and like there were some young
honeys yeah and they were sexy so we're
let me just tell you something you're
sitting at the table vip treatment
because of brenda's job
like that right so we get these bad
girls next to us chappelle scene
like two bad girls they just standing up
talking and like we have like four empty
chairs so i'm like i'm gonna be nice
i'm not you know i get looks all night i
want to see what it's looking like so i
go like hey
i push the chair out all gentlemen like
i said hey you want to sit down and she
looked she was like i'm good and she
like literally
didn't look at me so i had to i was like
you know
we were naples three or four three three
yeah yeah we were
surprising really two no i thought we
would kind of run
we was yeah you don't hear about naples
in these streets like that no
man and how did it make you feel how did
it make me feel yeah to think that you
were going to go away and being hot [ __ ]
and then
i felt fine yeah i worked out there he
worked out every day for motivation
we're going to be some austin sevens oh
they like them thick down here
yeah we're all set up in seven
awesome four mm-hmm oh austin because
university of texas is right there too
oh yeah yeah no we're right on sixth
street but big guys like
you know he's awesome if he's an eight
if he's an eight in l.a yeah
awesome different [ __ ] 12. bro they
like
like defensive lineman down there
they're like big boys big boy he's
probably not like lighting the ass i'm
too lightning
bro remember when we remember when we
got in thursday night and nothing was
open we
nobody ate all day oh and the only thing
that was open was mcdonald's
so we go through the drive-through at
mcdonald's like oh i'm about to
take this [ __ ] oh how about come out
this menu
everybody he's like get ready i was like
damn dog i'm paying for it take it easy
we get the mangoes yo man give me six
chicken nuggets
he goes give me a six piece chicken
nugget a sprite
i had to make chicken as well though
that'll be chicken bro he didn't even
finish his nuggets i ain't finished my
duckies at all
but it's just nuggets but again it's
it's like listen again
fasting i've been fasting all day right
happy ramadan
yeah hold on his ramadan
it's
hate on your religion your ramadan ain't
like khabib's drama
your [ __ ] he had he was eating one day i
go what the
he had a uh gatorade go what the [ __ ]
having a robin on you guys
oh my dad said i can just cheat today
and then prolong here
i can make it up it's a makeup day
listen that ain't the way this works
okay it's not but again we've been
traveling all day as soon as we got in
i it's nothing to eat we didn't have
water or something like that so i'm like
okay mcdonald's you don't break your
fast
for mcdonald's you know mcdonald's is
not the best of foods but mcdonald's was
nighttime so you can eat during the
night mcdonald's was like mcdonald's
ain't you're like
12 eight promised you ate during the
middle of the day during yeah you had
like we got the breakfast sandwiches and
you got a breakfast
burrito that was the next day i'm sorry
we talking about on thursday it was so
funny because he he just walked up and
grabbed a gatorade i'm like man the sun
is out yeah yeah yeah
he said oh i talked to my daddy
a lot of stress all right i didn't eat
my dad was dealing with bro
you wouldn't shut up oh my god
oh yeah it's in the back
oh you got it yeah what happened uh my
dad like again i was we had to pay
like hundred dollars to get it out to
get it out yeah
and so you got it out got it selling
this thing yeah let's sell it
yeah let's sell it i'm gonna have brian
johnson or marty create a graphic and
we're gonna
find a kid to sell okay i gotta you
gotta see when he first got it go to my
story chat oh you po
you went with her yeah you had to take
him to it
on sunday uh yeah damn you're a good
friend man
yeah look at the water sheila back
sheila back man watch who watch a rabbit
go look what that person said sheila
she doesn't sound like she had cody with
that
guy oh you posted picture you and him
getting
oh yeah i got sheila oh yeah i posted
yeah recent picture
so we selling sheila or what yeah
yeah that's uh yeah look at look at that
he's doing that thing i'm selling big
mama um
uh i got an offer this weekend uh five
thousand dollars was the highest
oh sell it huh sell it no sell it yeah
but five thousand great offer sell that
though
no but again i think it worth five grand
i know it's worth seven
so i'm thinking i'm thinking like yo if
you can beat that or just come close to
seven grand
get it off my hands hey
or more uh seven close it has to be
close to seven now if you talk about
sixty five hundred
i got that what about what about fifty
eight hundred yeah i'm sorry
hell yeah yeah see you because you're
not a regular person i'm not
yo she what i'm saying bro that's the
best value that's value right that's
really boring
you get that you get that some [ __ ]
detail you get that radio fix
or you can or you could add the
bluetooth speaker with it listen okay
i'm saying oh but but buy him a new yeah
get a new bluetooth
or sign the hood i sign the hood sign up
someone did come and say hey why he
missing a lug nut
on the bottom
so you drove chappelle to work today nah
so we drove separately because i got
xbox after this
but yeah i'm selling it for we're gonna
sell this thing and get what
we're gonna get uh yeah man we still we
i we still haven't like solidified that
all right two things two choices we're
getting the bmw m4
i'm leaning that towards jay because jay
was like that but they also fans was
like yo bmw
m2 competition well that's the best one
what's the m2
no i wouldn't go with the m2 i go i'd go
with the m4 personally
you don't you have an m2 no i have a
430i
430i yeah i love that m2 competition 52.
yeah we're gonna have to get this bad
[ __ ] used to get it used okay
[ __ ] yeah yeah that'd be frosty oh [ __ ]
yeah rolly boy look at that one that's
hard
that is hard hell yeah okay so yeah just
like i let the fans
decide man we'll get the m2 or the uh m4
oh yes
put uh put a pole up on the fighter and
the kids okay the page
well yeah like show a picture of each
god that m4
is that front yeah and damn how how much
is the m4
yeah how much do you use them for chin
use now because we're gonna have five
ground to put down yeah
so that means you're gonna finance
around 50 something okay
and plus i'm uh my credit is great well
yeah yeah
what year though i'd go 2016 might be
cheaper
because they all they changed the body
style a little bit so they depreciated
i feel like they depreciate a little bit
so you might be able to get oh yeah
and then yeah and m4 for mac a little
cheaper cheaper okay
so you said 2016. dude let's get the
titties out and go drop top you want the
drops oh damn that 2 on 17
44. so that means you finance 39 daddy
i'm with that
and look at that yeah but that's in west
palm beach that's the la prices
uh it'll probably be the same well
there's a white one in monbella for 47.
oh okay that means we're fine okay do
you want white
well i want red interior i want red and
white red you want that cat what the cat
has that
yeah they're red interior give me that
cat or black and red but i'm looking
forward to rub it on oh
hold on hold on go up chin there's one
in ontario black with red leather
51 okay it's a little higher where where
where where do you want it
right there dog it could be you know the
inside chin
how long yeah is that red or brown i
don't see anything inside this
definitely
red there we go
yes sir where's that channel where is
that chin in ontario california oh we
can negotiate that
okay 51. 58 give him five grand
down down that means we're financing 43.
payments will be around 750 800 a month
they only they only do two doors for
this yeah that's what i wanted that's
all he needs all right let's go
what i need i was all you need that
could be you that's a hell god those
seats are
sick look at that yeah that's what i'm
saying that could be me god talk about a
comma
yeah cause the whole weekend brendan was
i was acting bro every time you got on
the phone
like man it's so weird we can't get it
around 50 million dollar card you're
talking about a cent chat
around all these nice cars because
you're going hard on us
pedro was giving us like great facts
about these 50 million cars showing us
all the
and i couldn't go there i'm like well
dad what they saying about he was like
bro now they're adding another 300
because i left the key my dumb my so
total to get it out was 1200 because i
took
that that's including dropping the key
yeah no no that's everything's included
yeah and plus when you when you had to
go to fedex to pay for that i had to pay
for
it so all that 1200 1200
and i'm calling my bank right now we
sell this thing five grand you got five
grand down five grand down
yeah so i gotta offer five thousand i
might just take it i would take that all
right well let's do it
well let's say yeah that's what happens
after episode i'm not signing i'm
getting a bidding war
oh okay get that [ __ ] up 5 500 maybe
six grand
i'm not doubting it i'll you by the if
you buy it in the next couple of weeks
you get to keep everything in the trunk
what's your name what's in the truck a
lot of [ __ ] like what
yeah i know just like a basketball
football boxing club
a scale this is the scale that b
brenner the chapelle stepped on get that
[ __ ] from the history
throw in the jerusalem slides
oh that's right and then let's let's go
and take out
uh a few hundo out of that five grand
because you need new luggage
yeah your knees my buddies walk through
the airport
the whole we got a shoe box is a grocery
bag
i'm like what are you doing i'm like
dude you can you please get something
i'm sorry i said hey dawg you go ahead
and not bring that luggage
the new luggage it's on me we have to
leave we actually
was embarrassed it was bad was like
you gotta we gotta do somebody i was
stressed out that day
wednesday we had to literally go to the
airport i'm thinking we're gonna drive
by my parents house so i can drop this
stuff
off and then go get my you know you know
what's weird
you had the duffel bag in the shoe box
yeah why didn't you just put the shoe
box in the duffel bag
instead of just carrying the shoe like
you were tearing up empty shoe boxes
this empty shoe through the airport with
this stuffing duffel bag
why didn't you just put the shoebox so
you're just chilling
i hadn't there's no room there was no
room in the shoe but uh my doctor felt
like
get out of here like there was like
there was room no and i don't know why
you're carrying that shoe box around
yeah i'm not selling gonna sell your
shoes why do you keep the box
anybody i got these cheeseburgers i
brought the witherspoons listen i don't
know about
real shoe heads they know they will i i
don't like dusting around my shoes so i
like to put them back as soon as i wear
my shoes i put them right back in i
respect all that so again
that's why i had the shoe box and what
was the slides going to go my slides my
jerusalem in the in the shitty duffel
bag you have from played against sports
i had a lot of speed
but i had a lot of things that we're
playing against
so i had a lot of clothes in my duffel
bag believe it or not i had a lot don't
don't bring that same energy to austin
dude
i know especially you're wondering why
we didn't get looks
don't try to blame me that's nice my
fault
to the comedy club you still carry the
shoe box that's how you roll it was the
wooden spoons
either way it was a lot going on last
week sheila free
i feel good texture i got something for
your ass oh you got something for your
ass hey
they bullied me they clowned me the
whole time i couldn't even have a
comfortable flight
because if jay jay was like oh you need
help oh yeah
well jay has that new luggage yeah yeah
they got that good luck
yeah [ __ ] we need i need you i can't
talk too much to my my bag's from
goodwill
yeah what are y'all talking about your
bag's not bad though i mean no one's
even like jesus christ chappelle
my duffle bag from roots of fight you
love them but your bags
it's all dirty because it's a white bag
it's all frumpy
and it does some parts don't zip up so
it looks
okay hey look i'll leave the bag in a
trunk if you just well we got we
we got a hey we upgraded me okay yeah i
got it
yeah i'm working out as a jeep we gotta
upgrade you too you can't do
get too comfortable you're right 100 000
followers 100 000 followers
not yet he's on podcast come on we got
it he got his own
i got cut wait shout out to cutting
weight wake up wait you got this yeah no
i got it i got it now i appreciate it i
believe in you yeah
yeah y'all bullied me in the [ __ ]
losing weight yeah and
you should wear you used to wear vans
dirty as hell
oh those came to already oh dude are
those ones you ordered
uh no these are the ones i ordered those
not awesome
it says love is title on them it's crazy
this dude named uh
used to wear those bruce lee's remember
those yeah i still got the bruce lee
bro they're fire fire they caught on
fire
it's a good thing right they caught on
fire please they still hold the [ __ ] up
again i'll be doing vampires i'd be
doing band pregnancy i got them yeah
those are those are house shoes man no
they're not
they're not studios man let me show you
how good they look in this picture
listen
speaking of threes and austin sevens
don't we have some submissions for
uh rape my mate what are we calling
my state rate my state this episode is
brought to you by
unleashed with dingo and danny a new
podcast fueled by monster energy unleash
gets up close and personal with the best
alternative action
and motorsports get ready for untold
stories career defining moments and
inside secrets from the world's best
athletes and trailblazers don't miss out
on all the action new episodes drop
every two weeks on mondays
listen wherever you get your podcast or
watch on monster energy's youtube
unleashed with danny and the dingo
fueled by monster energy
what do you got chin there was some
dudes trying to uh get rated after the
show oh yeah yeah
we're coming up to what am i what am i
outside i'm like bro if you don't get
out of my face
he was like what are you doing pictures
of the girls my dude what's my girl man
like well do you probably think she's
attacked wait this is this is so we got
a raid watch
yeah i found some [ __ ] uh oh you wanna
watch your photo first
damn nah forget that [ __ ] his phone yeah
hey no hey this is your mom
look at them hold the [ __ ] up bam look
at them hold the [ __ ] up
they look great you wanna make it
reality dingus
[Applause]
do they not look good there i'm not
asking them i like them we all
performing
but my socks got holes in them oh my god
something always has to happen you look
like you're right but your bell can
surprisingly sing
especially especially like while
alternative song came in the car
oh it was under oath god that was great
yeah i was feeling it dude i was like
[ __ ] yeah i don't know uh it was uh
high above me she's so hot no no no
that's not the one
that we were driving to the airport yeah
oh yeah that was a [ __ ]
yeah that was dude all right what's up
so we have a new segment rate my state
people send submissions they send the
submission to thick boy ride
at gmail.com if you want you pick
uh featured on rate my state here's
amanda what do you know about amanda
from ontario canada shout out to canada
mother of three a nurse in school
boy then and she looks like that kids
are lucky
after three the kids are lucky well
here's the thing we know amanda getting
it in because she's 24. she's 25.
yeah and she's a mom of three already so
she's she is so you know she's got it
like that
yeah amanda now this is ontario canada
ontario before i give her a rating let
me show me where ontario's at
pretty sure ontario's uh is it the east
east coast pretty sure
canada is so [ __ ] big man i don't
know
dude canada's locked the [ __ ] down
so yes okay so it's east
i think i got wildlife and help it's
next to quebec
ottawa okay ottawa's in ontario okay i
know where that's at now
it's in ottawa is kind of near toronto
you say don't worry about it she got the
maple maple leaf hitters out the front
yeah she's a mother of three but again
is this it or is there another picture
just a two
bro we can't see her cause she's
covering her face right there oh look at
her right there oh yeah she's a
beautiful face i didn't see it
i would say she is ontario eight
okay what'd you give her chapel i was
gonna give her a nine okay i'll give her
a tarot nine i get eight point three
she got the maple leaf [ __ ] hitters
dude
what do you think her la rating would be
l.a
christian good call no she's she's a
seven
seven l.a that body that mommy i saw
that today in pilates
i i'll give it like a six
no she's at least a seven layer that's
cause i'm in la six
and she's tatted up she's that and she
has her [ __ ] together yeah throw that in
she's a nurse in school beast momma
three oh yeah she got three oh my gosh
she got kids yeah
let's have a look in the room and for
her to be a seven in l.a
that's great you're right them tits make
her seven let's be real here
i mean that's all she has and she has
those piercing blue eyes probably a
positive
super nice from canada and i love that
as a car
i love that honey blonde kind of
hairstyle i love that those are
highlights
highlights yeah set of lipsticks
honeycomb
dude she she's a stone cold la7
i'd say ontario eight or nine la seven
what
did that honeycomb block well you just
saved her hair after cereal
she got them sugar smacked eyes she got
that kool-aid smile
she got the fruity loom flips she got
them fruity pebble tits
you describe her like y'all want to
describe it
we got some coco chris titties down i
got them
toast crunch teeth what
she got that raisin bran hairline
what the [ __ ] and she got nutrients
so the johnny m rate my state johnny m's
from indiana
and he's he says he's in la three ooh
papa
i dis just this is no i guess
i don't know how old he is this is the
only picture he has three of them there
oh he's a team on the left yeah
yeah the other guy didn't have a hand
oh it was oh my bad
it's a strong hand
you look at that picture i got to know
how old he's obviously 20
mid 20s that would help if we had he's
also a [ __ ]
veteran you [ __ ] he says ellie
definitely hired an la3 he looks like a
dime piece there that other one
go the other one but this is that the
boxing match though still i like
yeah oh i can't see you can't see him
oh cause the camera oh what the hell
that's like a huge picture
just just being a veteran out of pure
respect can't give him lower than a five
no he's above a five
well in indiana that first picture in
the uniform i would give him an eight
that's an indiana
a yeah yeah he's at la i'd say
five point five point five
point five five and a half bouncing off
you five and a half yeah yeah i give him
la five and a half well we don't even
know his height you know because la is
big out here in height
so send in like your everything all your
descriptions
height weight all that stuff i don't
need your weight yeah i would like your
weight
well the weight size too no i just went
are we getting measurements
like well now now i'm 5 10.
well you are la2 because we're super
superficial
i know you just said it old ass kids i'm
five eight four hundred
they're falling on hard times from high
school i just sat next to brenda shop
and j
shot so what so age weight
height yeah what else that does that's
it
i give him an la five and a half like
chappelle indiana indiana
heart eight especially that picture
strong eight strong eight
honest eight i'm gonna give him a six
because he's a boxer
all good yeah la-6 yeah what do you what
han kat what are you giving oh le6 i
don't you talking about
indiana i give him an la6 la6 yeah
that's fair yeah
he's in that range though shout out to
johnny shout out johnny
this is shannon samuels okay shannon
let's see if she oh yeah i didn't think
shannon was gonna look like that he was
a guy he looked like an older version of
stevie that's the situation you're right
i think stevie's future yeah
i'm very excited now this guy will not
pass the drug test
and he has tattoos 47. his tattoos
are clearly from the 90s yeah that
mortal kombat tattoo
does does his tattoo say six nine in it
or is it like an infinity yeah
that's that old cancer sign thing or
whatever right i thought it was like
is that the infinity sign i think it's
like cancer oh
like the the horoscope yeah yeah either
that or capricorn somebody this this
this boy is bodied up brought it up and
he's 47 father of one
yeah uh an elderly seven let's say lewis
st
louis he's a nine he's a nine lewis yeah
he come here he's seven i give him an
eight yeah give me for l.a
that body for dead bodies
dude that that planet fitness body yeah
that's not playing that lunker ball
that's not a funny
fitness
look at those obliques down to the dick
root
seven eight that's a seven in l.a oh he
would kill the game in l.a
seven he totally would we don't know his
height
i mean father he's a dad too yeah i'm
gonna give him a whole i'm gonna give
him a st
louis heart eight maybe a nine depending
what he's wearing
i'll give him an la7 at 47. perfect
that's perfect yeah
i got the same thing st louis nine my
boy's bodied up look at his chest
what you got chappelle uh st louis uh
nine i give him an la-8
that's fair okay
saint louis last one shyla hopefully
it's a girl i would imagine
i thought shannon hawaii
hawaiian doesn't live in hawaii hawaiian
mom of three boys
she looks so friendly i know her she's
got a great oh
is this a video no it's not a picture
from the video and then oh damn
girl okay don't hurt him now in that
dress she got the moana tits at the top
you're welcome she got ladies like
ariana grande
she's 30 mom of three that's the thing
dude mama of three
yeah does somebody's body yeah yeah
oh i don't so yeah we don't know where
she lives dude
that would help i don't know yeah let's
say she's like
yeah she's hawaiian so maybe she grew up
there i haven't been to hawaii
i've never been in hawaii either we're
supposed to be on i don't know how to go
to hawaii
what's up i'm about to go to hawaii for
what in may for stevie's birthday
you're taking him to hawaii yeah was his
birthday the 20th uh the
19th i knew i was i was close you're
very close are we in
stevie hanging out with alpacas and [ __ ]
now yeah
really kept saying stevie says one more
[ __ ] picture
like our group choice would be so fun
we'd light each other up
now steve like had a great day with kat
with alpacas i'm like
bro bro you got one more save this for
your facebook stephen
i don't want to see you another [ __ ]
alpaca
he said pictures he said six creatures
of alpacas i'm like dude back to back to
back to back
no one said anything after the first one
he left the first one like five minutes
he said that one i said i said justin
got teeth like an alpaca
remember that i didn't want to laugh
just go we'll continue with the
statement
so but then i was like all right one
pick of an alpaca all set bubba
six and then the and then his comments
were the same as like a parent would say
oh yeah like the cash yeah he's like
cat's fun but i think this alpaca's
taking my heart
it was so [ __ ] and no one replied
no one replied yes and he jumped and was
like oh no i i
i gave the ha ha are you getting it i
didn't hold on what did blow the bell
post to francis
i feel like oh gotcha it's just me
talking [ __ ] all right cool
um yeah it was interesting man stevie
posted like a straight up dad
he was lit from alpacas
who posted cat yeah i saw this
i think still stevie put it on his page
oh no yes steve you put it on his put on
his page
what did what did cat say though let me
let's finish that option
i get the alpaca hype hold up now
and then let me see our pictures okay
tina eat your food is that from napoleon
dynamite yeah teen nature
teenager quesadilla right it was
enchiladas
tina yeah you still here it's enchiladas
who's in challenges
here's the thing about alpaca's cat and
stevie should probably look this up look
at his teeth
um the thing is
he's tough
another picture of just the alpaca
i said no i said this picture i zoomed
down on packaging look at justin's teeth
zooming on that out back his teeth see
my guy my man fight back at least i know
he can't even fight
he can fight back in the group chat that
group chat is the
arena we light each other up we don't
respond to that he was like
oh yeah yeah yeah
he said look at just the teeth god also
these are all the pictures
i pet the nose for you it's super soft
it is you would love it
where did you guys go to do this uh in
palmdale the farm is sweetwater alpaca
farm
how far is that uh maybe 45 minutes from
l.a oh not very fast it's not terrible
it isn't bad we're a bunch of kids there
uh no there was another couple who came
before
all grown adults grown adults
interesting yeah right loving
loving the alpacas here's a little fact
about alpacas i looked more into it
because uh steve was talking about
buying alpaca the thing about alpacas
is uh they're real cheap to buy but then
they're a beast to maintain so
everyone's trying to give alpacas away
oh you have to have two of them because
they're social animals if there's just
one it gets depressed
so you gotta get two you gotta get two
and you gotta [ __ ] eat like
a certain amount of acres to have them
roam around it you know stevie does
steve you wanna say i wanna buy an
outback that's a bad investment bubble
you gotta have two
anything you try to house at home now
i've never seen him happier in my life
though
he loves that pack he loves alpacas i
can't right
from just from the group tag that yeah
he's [ __ ] no like when you
the six pictures we saw when you see him
in a vicinity of an alpaca
like he changes he becomes like this
middle-aged mother maybe maybe it's like
his spare time like gets his
i think it is i really should buy one
bring on the planes and [ __ ]
you can do that if you get no uh
some [ __ ] brought a turkey they don't
know how that is
they just recently like only because
certain animals you can see a dog on the
planet i grabbed a flamingo on there
yeah they had a bunch of stuff on a
plane yeah you could say they tried to
bring them on they tried to be on pizza
oh yeah peacock there it is i've heard
of squirrels before but now you can't do
it it's only dogs
only dogs yeah really you don't even see
dogs at the airport anymore
people are chilling out on that yeah
even that you have to have like a
certain type of dog too because there
are certain airlines that won't let
pitbulls on
that's [ __ ] up man yeah pipples are
great i heard
people like attacked a kid face in an
airplane
really bad yeah what we can't have that
hey that we we didn't give that
hawaiian moana honey uh a rating oh
let's finish up the ratings oh yeah
i'm sorry uh i got eight in hawaii we're
on that warm luke bath you've ever been
hawaii
you ever seen that hawaiian eight no
dude
okay and she's not gonna want hawaii
let's is beyond she's pretty though man
she's really pretty
again the mama three gets me man
hawaiian
are you gonna stand by yeah i've never
been i've never been hawaii either i'm
gonna give up hawaii
i'll give her a macadamia nut seven
what is that
i give her i give her i give her a la
seven i give her a hawaii eight
i'm not gonna be mean okay well what'd
you give her in la
i was gonna say seven i'll say that yeah
yeah she's pretty hot man
dude she's she's a naples nine those old
dudes would be all over her dude
bro we saw how old is old
65 and above i'm sorry that's the
average age 65 and there's
money money down there i'm young girl
stupid looking down
those older dudes have younger women out
there man good for them
yeah yeah hey i get this i mean i get it
do what you do yeah a lot of money
living in that mansion
she passed away nobody hear this dude
she was with a very old dude
and michael smith anna nicole smith yeah
you ever seen her when she was young
no no bombshell what was it
before she got big right trim spa that's
what she had uh yeah yeah
she owned that yeah she made a lot of
money off that i don't know she was with
that older dude
yeah yeah he was dude he was on
death doorstep when they met and then
she blew up
yeah she went nice no no i mean weight
wise blew up look she was
gorgeous gorgeous she was she was like a
straight playmate she looked beautiful
oh that's what
she was a playboy mate that's her her
story's pretty sad if you look into it
because
she got really into drugs and her son
passed away
and then she went just completely
downhill didn't she but she was a
straight-up tennis
she has another kid though she was butt
naked in the movie right
uh she's a playboy go go to her and her
man look at the litter man oh that's
hugh hefner if you go to her man her
man's
i mean i had to tie him right there the
one that she had the kids with
no no no that was from that that man
yeah
wish you can pretend that hey you know i
mean good for him
you know he was stupid rich good for him
but uh
what did he do i printed money i bet oil
let's just check you oil you was stupid
rich i remember
but then uh clearly she was like no he's
my soul mate i'm like [ __ ]
he's 89 years old yeah you know he's
beverly hills housewife
he died before she died right yeah yeah
but then there was a huge fight with his
family and heard it
like over over the will over like the
will and stuff i mean
come on how long were they married
uh i don't know so he was an oil tycoon
oh yeah
oh wow they met when he was in a
wheelchair
from texas right i would imagine
all they met when he was in a wheelchair
yeah
she said what those wrinkles do baby i
guess so
dude you listen she was gonna fat
stipend
every month but you don't work man
you're doing work you're doing work is
it worth
that so that's what i think we're like
it was worth it for you with that old uh
lady you was getting with
no no she was only with him for a year
two uh yeah a year after they
married he died after daddy after a year
yeah she was smart
he was so old too i did he's gonna go
soon yeah
that's my thing like when we were at
that restaurant on saturday night when
it was like one the morning people were
leaving we saw just that
young asian dime walking out with that
that guy must have been 80 something oh
yeah
they were walking to his [ __ ] belt or
something like she she's about to earn
that money tonight do you feel he was
feeling it yeah
he was all up on her ass yeah i chill a
little pride
[Laughter]
i mean he got that tommy bahama shirt on
that [ __ ] was on button
do you think they're ever in love never
i think they care about them but if he
was broke she would not be there but the
girl was making
she was no she was but she wasn't making
no choice she went [ __ ]
she was like doing some playboy [ __ ] but
she's not balling
like look at all those do they make a
lot of money off playboy no really
world do you live in like things you're
tripping think about the girls on the
hugh hefner show remember that show
what are they called boys the primates
are playmates
um oh these girls next door and they all
live together yeah
one wrote a book saying like saying all
the [ __ ] they had to do to have
like yeah she was recently on her daddy
what do you mean she wouldn't call her
daddy tried saying she'd have sex with
him
first of all you ain't living at hugh
hefner's house without sucking dick
there's one way to earn your rent girl
no he was getting with them
oh they wrote a book on it yeah and he
was like super kinky
is he rapping our dog yeah yeah i think
she was one of the only girls who didn't
sign an nda
oh you had to sign an nda for that yeah
and that's the only reason why she could
get away with writing so those girls
don't
make that much money like being in those
men that's why they're sucking them old
balls and [ __ ] man
usually you're kind of just with the guy
and they finance your lifestyle but you
don't actually have any like
money yourself like your own yeah it's
kind of like me yeah
so basically it's like oh like i'll buy
you this purse pay for your rent
and whatever but the moment we break up
you have nothing i used to have all the
stuff that i bought for you but now i'm
not paying you did you do that cat
no i don't like being told what to do
well hold on let's say well he's not
telling what to do but let's say you
don't have only fans you have nothing
you just work on finding the kids
you're making a living but you're not
like no i don't like being told what to
do so
but what if he's nice and you tell him
what to do like he likes to get bossed
around but
you know you live in bel air you're
driving to bends i feel like i know how
that ends and i don't like it that's why
i worked four jobs at the beginning of
my career did you ever have any offers
yeah i had offers oh at that apartment i
used to work at that boujee one i got
tons of offers to be like
girlfriends or like sugar mom or like a
sugar baby but i always said no you want
to be a sugar baby
no i know how that ends you have no
respect for yourself kind of right
it's just one of those things where like
with him dying you taking all this
forward
usually no usually they uh give it away
i don't think they write them in the
will yeah usually very rare they do
very rare you suck that dick right after
a good after a good dick suck he was
like
go ahead and write this girl i'd have
like two to three good years that i'd
have to figure out the rest of my life
i'd rather not those two or three years
would be so lit i couldn't be a sugar
baby either
yeah no like in my head i wish i have
you ever had offers from like an older
cougar no the hamper not that i could
think about this
no none of those none of those
cheerleading moms but hey man
you know if you just want to you just
want to chill
no oh like one of those old maple ladies
who want a
nice chocolate man oh yeah what like
that that could have been you
oh there was ladies that asked for a
picture with spell and she goes i just
love she goes i just want to come up to
you
and i was like and she's like i just
want to take a picture with you she
wanted that panther yeah
yeah she wanted that pants too
she took big shoes all up on you she's
like i just love big pads yeah i was
like okay i thought she just yeah
after my brother was like about to [ __ ]
do you feel like she took advantage of
you no no you just wanted a picture
you're gonna go on a pr tour like
[ __ ] terry crews
i was in naples i was in naples she
grabbed my hand i'm saying that's how
terry crews sounded that's how
good morning america everything wrote a
book about it they'd be hating on terry
crews
i like i like terry crews come on dude
you had a great career man you don't
need to do all this
porn addiction porn i mean you watch
porn dog yeah
and also define addiction thank you
because
there's some people i mean nah a porn
addiction is like you finish
all porn
i think it's uh like jacking off like
non-stop like seven no it's gotta be
like multiple yeah i think they
uh interpret addiction as anything that
uh
impedes on your daily life let's see a
porn addiction for the person becoming
emotionally depend on porno to the point
that it interferes with their daily life
relationships ability to function
um 2019 study suggests that the
prevalence of these disorders may be
about three to six percent however the
rates have been difficult to determine
yeah who's really given into that keep
going signs of porn addiction let's see
if we're addicted to porn guys
uh the diagno let's see some indications
that porno might be causing problem
include a person's sex life becomes less
satisfying
yeah sometimes some dirty [ __ ] on
there uh cause
relationship issues are making person
feel less satisfied with the partner
yeah you can't put cocky in your girl's
face man
a person engages in risky behavior to
view porno
such as doing so at work okay oh [ __ ]
yeah that's another lie
ignore responsibilities to view porn the
progressively more extreme porn okay
feel frustrated or shamed after viewing
porn sometimes i do
sometimes i feel bad for the girl like
god damn girl all those guys
uh they want to stop using this i know
what the [ __ ] do you watch what's in
your search history
all those guys when he
they spend large sums of money these
porno to cope with sadness anxiety
insomnia yeah sometimes i can't sleep
i'll check it out
i mean i tried you having an addiction
yeah it's starting to sound like a
little bit
he said if i can't say i'll check it out
i go live now
i agree with on that like when you can't
sleep you up
something to do let me go get one off
you know i mean and that's
that those be the best ones cause you
found a great video got your headphones
in i don't know about you
i i really like to run the water you're
in the uh in the bathroom yeah about
them yeah
nobody can hear me well yeah because
that mean if you well sometimes like
netflix so you know when you go to
netflix just
searching and searching yeah sometimes
at the porno i'm just
happy do i want that one i can't i can't
commit to any options and then i'll be
like ah that first one was good now you
can go back through all the pages and
find it
so where the [ __ ] you were i hate that
were you searching for a good porn video
and you click on one and you like let me
just see the one underneath and you look
at that thumbnail
that one's
accuracy of this [ __ ]
i'll be like brendan make them know
because next time you do this
remember yes
whatever tina goes to the adventures
yeah you remember tina black remember to
know why i need help
in my head i'm like yeah you got this
that next time it doesn't even
cross my mind like bro yo yes bro
crossed my mind yeah well then when it
does show up for like [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell yeah let's go pornhub
i went to i went to a pornhub like
vortex because i was sitting on that
toilet so long my leg went to sleep
because i was like i couldn't find it
was just so many dope videos back to
back to back and i couldn't decide
i was like bro i've been in this
bathroom for 30. sometimes when it's
like you might like this i'm like
where in the world did you get the idea
of suggestions
under what impression i never did i ever
give you
i know that i'm in the chat today
yeah right but it look like some bad
[ __ ] like god damn i'm not clear i'm
like
oh they [ __ ] you up like that yeah i'm
like oh hopefully nobody sees my search
here
you'll see jesse hey hey you porn in
what you were on
did you get the idea that i was into
when you watch porn do you need like a
back story like do you have to have the
video have a
i fast forward to it really sometimes i
check out that
i can't do that i can't do that i know
what i know
don't get me wrong you just walk into
somebody [ __ ] yeah i can't do that i
need to know how they
mess either where they're like oh
i ordered pizza hours ago it's like what
the [ __ ] and this bad
writing yes give me the imagination for
what it is
i'll tell you who does the best job is
the taxi guy oh
yeah i mean i'm not such a good actor oh
my god damn how's she gonna pay for this
yeah
that's great johnny sins not gonna lie
pretty solid actor in his
so who's that guy who's that guy on pub
public agent
who's that guy he's a great phenomenal
actor who like he's just like offered
him money on the street he's like yo uh
we on the map reality bros i think it is
is it i have no idea i think well i
thought y'all said that they they know
like oh yeah
none of it's real it's not a big room
some of the amateur [ __ ] on this reel
yeah oh really mm-hmm
that now they got on pokemon they got
yeah now the only fans like guys to be
hitting it they'd be saying that they're
on the uh
pornhub mm-hmm yeah wait only fans go
down to tricky road man
what do you mean because they start
there and then they're like i'm making
money like
what's the i gotta upgrade i gotta level
my [ __ ] up
and then next thing i was just doing
full-blown porn and you just put it on
yeah only fans yeah
with hey with that being said the way
you start is how you finish
why you got to do the motion yeah i
don't know what that means all right
let's get some current events alrighty
okay so uh last week when we talked
about colton
underwood coming out and i asked the
question why is he doing like a
press tour for it it turned out that he
was getting paid and
shortly after that and that interview
on i believe was good morning america
right yeah he
uh got an announcement that he's getting
his own netflix show
about him coming out as a gay man and
that's why he's gonna be like the
bachelor but with gay boys
no i think it's more of a reality uh a
reality show kind of following him and
just following his journey yeah i'm not
into that
[ __ ] that i'm i'm down for him just be
with a truckload of dudes like
choosing to do that that would be the
bachelor's yeah yeah they don't have to
put on netflix
nobody has that why not being a gay
bachelor i mean it would do
terrible ratings on like abc or whatever
but but on netflix i feel like it'd be
great i'd be
lit hey why is lance best he'd be like
gary i give you a rose
lance best has a podcast and he was
talking about it saying that he's happy
this guy came out but he thinks that
there's gonna be some initial backlash
from the gay community how are you gonna
be mad that the dude was like hey i'm
coming out there like yo we'll give you
whatever
four million yeah what are you doing if
they had that opportunity they would say
the same
absolutely just because nobody was
surprised when lance came out
he was all mad oh lance wasn't hating on
him he was like i'm really happy for him
the only issue is i think he needs to
brace himself for a certain amount of
hate to compensate
just stay offline and look at your bank
account son yeah but yeah he's coming
out with the netflix show
oh but it sucks it's not the bachelor
gases maybe that would be the next thing
after that i mean abc so whoa put your
money where your mouth is that might be
i would never be on track with a bunch
of things
with a bunch of gods just
[Laughter]
[ __ ] thing a thick boy production
yeah
you said it's not gonna be on abc uh no
no we'll be on netflix it'll be on
netflix
you know that show would be dope man
anything but [ __ ]
how long were you thinking of that joke
see i would have went i was i would have
went racial with anything but coloreds
ooh what is it that's right that's
honestly that's what i thought you
know but it was it's a lot it's a lot of
black gay guys out there as well so i
didn't want to go with that
what no there's a lot of black gay guys
in the world
yeah yeah but what's have to do with abc
don't have any no
no lead black gay guy has a show on abc
uh have you seen uh
uh how to kill it how to get away with
murder yeah okay is that okay
okay they also anything about color they
also have like uh
blackish black blackish blackish and
then uh what's the
other one still there was like a for the
blue
still black oh no uh mixes
there's been like so many of them
there's been too many of them in my
opinion but
britain is like where's whitish i'm just
kidding
it's called mage with children
and it was a huge success great success
it's also called friends
it's all called seinfeld yeah three's
company
three's company was great you couldn't
make that show today
why a guy a singer island with two
[ __ ] yeah
who was just talking about that but his
character was
only when uh mr furley
would come around or mr furley i'm mr
roper yeah mr robert mr furley whenever
they would come around
he he would say he was gay that's what
his character did
right yeah yeah yeah
there was a show like the bachelorette
but i think it's called finding prince
charming and it was a gay guy who was
gorgeous and when i was shooting the
show for the history channel
they were shooting the reunion next door
and i had to get a pig
because me my girl were obsessed bring
i think it was on uh oxygen that was oh
it was it was a gay dude it was a bit
the bachelor but for gay
gays oh so they have already had this
show but they're not bachelor level like
their dates they went to like
[ __ ] earth cafe like it was low earth
yeah there's not but they're not going
to
there he is robert roberts
yeah bodied up doggy oh he is going i
got a picture of him said to my
grandmother look who i ran to she went
holy [ __ ]
you thought i had a picture with
leonardo dicaprio we were so crunk
bro is that his real abs that's what's
gonna say too they look kind of fake
yo he's gay so oh
dude come on look i feel like some of
the best looking men are gay hold on i'm
glad
he's on fire yeah he flame the show was
fantastic
is it one season they're trying to find
only with a different guy
the only one sees oh yeah i think it got
cancelled okay look at his abs
it looks like implants doesn't it am i
tripping it looks like it looks so good
it looks it looks so good and it looks
like a little
hole it's like a lot of hard work just
sound like a chill
no no if it just doesn't for some reason
actually i don't think he has like
implanted i think that dude probably
legit works out
i think he's just yeah yeah
that's probably good right now all right
dude he kind of looks like benedict
cumberbatch a little bit
whoever oh him really hey better
kill this [ __ ] man one line don't [ __ ]
it up man you don't [ __ ] like
you know what it is
what's those pants these ones these are
uh i have those for you
yeah oh yeah they're my size
hell yeah remind they're here today i
love you guys
love you too what he never says love you
no i know all right love you guys
malik have to leave yeah you have to go
you're going to shoot a commercial
he's going he's going to he's got his
one line dude i hope he didn't
[ __ ] it up it's his moment to shine he's
he's actually a really good actor
is he he's actually really really good i
watched uh
he was in that um burning sands
burning sands i watched that on netflix
yeah do you have a big role in that yeah
really that's cool yeah he has a lot of
lines and [ __ ]
he does a lot in that movie he's really
good that's cool
sweet all right what else you got jen
this right here so the pentagon came out
and confirmed that a
leaked video of a ufo from the navy is
actually real
here's my thing with these and i do
believe in ufos and all that [ __ ]
i know the pentagon confirms the leak
footage um
it's re so it's a real footage by uh the
navy
out of all the technology we have why is
it always so goddamn blurry
let me see why is there no legit footage
well yeah what is this well i don't know
what i'm looking because it's old
brendan
no it's not
so it's just flashing like how do we not
have better footage of this
how do we no isn't this like old like
videos they've had for years
i don't uh i think this particular one
is fairly recent maybe a few years old
oh really yeah look at that thing they
didn't confirm
a bunch of videos they just confirmed
this one was real
crazy is that they're confirming that
they're real that's them confirmed they
don't know what they're not saying
yeah they're not saying anything we
don't know what the [ __ ] it is because
that's what ufo is unidentified
flying object you know it could be a
drone for all we know and they just
didn't it's not a drone
well they know it's not a drone because
how fast it goes yeah because it'll go
from
and then it just levels appears right
and we don't have the technology as i'm
saying we don't have it but i'm sure
other countries who knows how how
advanced their technology is they
shouldn't hide it from
china they're definitely going to hide
us it could be chinese or russian [ __ ]
oh russian uh i i'd say chinese
chinese for sure yeah i never care for
this stuff
you just can't get into it that's not
intriguing to you that the government
said it's
oh wow it's never been intriguing to me
wow that's like
it is what it is because i don't know
what the i don't know what else to say
it was like in your face and you saw
something for sure you probably dig it
but if it's just like a blinking light i
just wish
i just wish we had a little clearer
picture like all the technology we have
like that right now iphone 12.
i know take good pictures i feel like
you were more excited for that lizard to
eat the roach
i was way excited for that that [ __ ] i
could get on board with that that was
for you
something's flying in there and i can't
tell how did nature's metal not
repost that dude that is they need to
get that as [ __ ]
that is nature's foot okay so this video
uh is of a man and his wife coming out
they're trying to get to a car
the woman is holding like a cage with a
small animal inside
and slowly you see as the runner in the
back
is like making her jog you see a bobcat
run
and it starts to attack the wife the
husband then runs and
pulls it off and starts yelling at it
like a small child you want
so chocolate like this yeah and then
i've seen bobcats they are not
i didn't see i didn't see this one was
like a small one
where does it come from what was she
holding a plate of food so he has
food and then she's gonna come it's a
frame
and she has a cage with her it seems
like there's a small animal inside
his fashion is [ __ ] awful oh my god
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
watch how calm he is when he's just
saying hi to the neighbor oh the
neighbor part yeah
he's like we need to watch this goddamn
car carol
and then so this is where it runs up
it runs up from another house because
she she's on the cat
she's holding a cage with something
inside
yeah i would have kicked it
down yeah oh yeah
i probably would have missed i would be
like oh [ __ ]
it's gonna ask neighbor asking all these
questions i know
what happened where is i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up he's like a bobcat
god damn yeah that is crazy okay that
was a mountain lion
is a video of two men running up to
another man getting out of his car they
try to rob him
of his car what seemingly looks like at
gunpoint
the guy isn't having it and he ends up
picking him up and tossing him to the
floor
both robbers tried to run away so yeah
point to get on his face guys
all right be cool man be cool be cool
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah bam oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
who's screaming screaming like that i
don't know
why is this i don't grab that gun i feel
like the gun might
take he literally like you know
warthogs get caught by lions or whatever
yeah that's what it sounds like that's
exactly what he sounded like
he said okay okay yeah that's what these
[ __ ]
criminals do dude god damn
they shouldn't yeah they they thought
wrong
i guess because he's a kid maybe he's
like [ __ ] i'll just let him go yeah yeah
why is this why is he crazy about that
[ __ ] again
yeah that screen makes me feel like it
was a kid it was like some stupid
teenager yep
yeah the gun probably was fake yeah
that's dumb as [ __ ] i saw this
six-year-old
she's so amazing i haven't seen this
watch dude she kills it
this is a this is a deep ass drop in
looks like a pool
watch
there no there's no volume chin it's
probably low i think it's music or
whatever
she a little dress yeah watch her that's
a deep
[ __ ] that is not little what a little
badass
god damn six years old that's insane
that's nuts
yup killing it so cute is that her
brother oh
i don't know i don't know if it's her
brother what he helped god what a little
battle
cute um and i saw this on adam ray's
account did you guys see this one no oh
yeah this is an older video i didn't
know okay so he just posted this
the only thing is this is a fake video
oh that sucks her name is lele pons and
she's known for doing like
she does vines and like her whole thing
was that she would trip in front of
stuff and like
embarrassed yeah she didn't want to she
does stuff like this where she falls
oh she got it yeah got me
oh yeah some guy goes this would be
great if it was real
that was hilarious do i think go away
she had an ass on her though
she did yeah you should see her before
and after photos
what's her name uh layla she's a huge
creator
oh okay here's a quick one this is just
floyd mayweather
with hair
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] he looks weird he looks like a
b
yeah he looks like a browner damn again
money done by
happiness my ass look at his hair i know
and his beard he had plugged inside yeah
wow just super hairy now good for him
man
he looks cool yeah yeah i actually like
him with the hair
it'll take a little time to adjust
because i he looks so different now
but it looks fine that's pretty much
it boys it's definitely awkward that's
it
that's it yeah he's always
his hair was always but his hair was
going though yeah
oh he's always i didn't know his hair
was going yeah he had here like that i
was wondering why he shaved his head
hold up scroll up to what he said about
jake paul
right there oh yeah that that was part
of the current events too but it's since
it's no
really i don't know how believable it is
what do you mean i mean i don't know
it's not in like all the big
news sexual assault stuff yeah i mean
it was a girl a tick-tock girl saying
that yeah yeah
but so think of the nerve for floyd
mayweather say this kid is so thirsty
he's harassing females that's like
michael jackson post a video of a guy
hanging out with kids but you believe
this guy
this is nuts oh [ __ ] some people
understand the word no
and then he doesn't leave comments he
does this all the time yeah he
for sure everyone little jelly monster
of jake paul man
i don't know i don't know why i don't
know much about him or anything
uh but i mean he wait he did what he
said he was going to do like yeah but
why why do people not like him because
he
oh no i guess he's known as a sort of a
troll he's like the most
he's like the most disliked guy on
youtube
uh i'm not i'm not the biggest fan of
jake i
been starting to like logan a little
more i just don't i'm not i'm not a fan
of jake but why
uh i just don't like his eye like i just
oh he's cocky
yeah and he thinks he's hot [ __ ] i i
hate it all like
trolling before a fight yeah i
understand but i just the [ __ ] he said
about mcgregor and his wife that that
was
too personal yeah that like that was
over the line like if i was mcgregor
i wouldn't have i wouldn't take the
fight like i'm saying if i was mcgregor
i would have shown up to jake paul's
house
with three million dollars cash and been
like listen i'm not going to give you
what you want i'm not going to fight you
on camera
you and i are going to fight right now
and i'm going to kick the [ __ ] out of
you and you
and you can keep the money but then
connor's not going to get paid on that
at that point i would like like i said
if i i'm saying if i was kind of i
wouldn't get like jake because
he crosses the line when he talks and i
like he's just a punk
like yeah he's just a punk also he said
something about uh
asking his wife and aspen just laughed
well he called her thick and i
i think that's a young person thing like
i like my wife though yeah he goes i'm
saying i don't get it i think she's sexy
yeah she's thick it's hot
you say i don't i don't get how that's a
dude is he not a he was he never like a
[ __ ] talker like when it came back
huge [ __ ] talker oh he was cute he
didn't seem to really
i also want to see him go up against a
real
stand-up boxer and still talk like fight
us real stand up fighter and talk to
[ __ ] like
ben askren great fighter like he can
fight but he's
you know he's never been a stand-up
fighter but here's my thing with all
this christian remember like everyone
keeps saying that it's a popular thing
to do hate on jake and i get why he gets
the hate
remember he only has three fights no no
i know and he like
he he does like who's your favorite
fighter boxer probably javonta davis
did you ever see javonte davis's third
fight ever
oh no yeah i know no i i agree with you
yeah like
it's [ __ ] no don't give me enough
like so everyone wants to like
every i think the problem is everyone's
putting jake in the same lane as like a
canelo alvarez
he's he's gonna take him he's in his own
world no don't get me wrong he he has a
really good potential like he has like
he has nice punches he has a lot of
power
and obviously you're gonna have a lot of
stuff to work on that early on
in your boxing career so i'm just saying
like maybe like if he was like a little
more humble like he thinks that he could
take on floyd mayweather
and that's ridiculous to me i mean so is
his brother but that they're just doing
it for paydays
you know that's that's like that tick
tock type of
generational [ __ ] yeah i yeah i think
the prom and the hate for switch from
the fight world comes on them
when people view it as the same as like
you know
izzy or [ __ ] kelvin gaslum like
they're in completely differently
yeah yeah i yeah i don't put too much
emphasis on i mean it's
they have they have their [ __ ] you know
what do you think about uh
isn't bryce hall fighting now what do
you think about that bryce hall the yeah
one of the tick tock
one of like a tick tock is starting to
try a box now too
apparently he has a fight coming up this
is where this see i think this is where
it's gonna get dicey because like i
think people are gonna see the fame and
the notoriety and the money jake's
making
but the other thing is jake and logan
were were athletes before they were tick
tockers like this
this i mean come on yeah jake uh logan
was like a pretty good wrestler
really good totally yeah really get in
ohio really oh he's just a tick-tock and
he wants to like
but that's the problem is now you can
get guys like this coming out where
that's where it becomes a [ __ ] show
is it because it's it's the money and
and they have nothing to do like romero
as a youtuber like they're they
constantly
come up with that off factor yeah that's
why logan paul created
a podcast which is one of the biggest in
the world now
he's doing we're making money off that
because that the shelf life of creating
that [ __ ] shock factor there's only
so much shelf life
you can only do it for so long that's
why jake's got into boxing but those
kids are
dedicating their athletes so it's like
this kid's just doing because like oh
look at jake
yeah and then but he doesn't want to do
it he's not really gonna do it
i mean i hope he does and i hope he gets
his ass beat but he probably will or
he's going to fight another youtuber
it's going to be a [ __ ] product and
there's a lane for it and he might make
a few bucks but
you know jake paul's like dedicate his
life to it yeah and that's why you're
seeing like you're not hard
whether they're shitty aren't you
hardest to knock the dude out in a
minute
if i ask you okay i can't just knock out
a problem if i asked you to fight one of
the camera guys out here it'd be tough
for you to knock him out
yeah it'd be tough and especially like
someone like ben
askren too i mean to knock him out
robbie lawler
yeah that's what i was just about to say
the the uh the fight where robbie waller
slammed ben askren
on his neck got on top of him and
started grabbing his face
knocked him out yeah and then ask him to
end up winning that fight
it's nuts that's why everyone again i
know people hate him and you have to you
know and
he does some terrible [ __ ] but as far as
fighting goes it's like three fights in
dude he's starching guys like there's
something there
i reason there's a lane for before
before that for that world yeah
like the problem is people as he's in
that world no one's
no one's beat him yet in that literally
elaine's world like look how many people
watched it
yeah i think how many people are asking
me about the fight in naples oh so many
people no one did
did you hear anyone mention whitaker no
more people ask you about the aspirin
and that's it
paul fighting like there's there's
something there yeah you know something
you guys watching cat what are you
saying were you stoked about it too
the fight yeah i ain't never been stoked
about the fight even this one jay paul
oh it's whatever to me
okay i've never been like we watched it
you were there but you weren't like yeah
you were asking questions but you're
right
i'll ask questions you wouldn't care if
we didn't watch it though no okay that's
it yeah would it like it's like the ufo
yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
it was like must-see tv for me like we
were i was like
we get off stage at 10 when we were
trying to figure out right the main car
the main fight won't start till probably
11 30 they got bieber before
we were like rushing to make sure i saw
it yep you didn't see the fight before
jake's with regis oh yeah
the guy pretended that he got hit yeah
i just wanted that he just wanted out
yeah i just wanted to make sure like
that was
insane that the whole thing was a [ __ ]
show yeah the production everything was
a show
in between two fights i felt like i was
watching like a virtual coachella
concert or something yeah it was nuts
like i said
it's celery rehab boxing yeah like there
are a bunch of has-beens
oscar de la hoya is on more cocaine than
god it's just like
it's a [ __ ] show that bella jojo cat i
love justin bieber i like all these yeah
they just need to tighten up their
production get rid of the circus
that belt looked like it was a bought at
party cd though that was another
pete davidson i mean the skits snoop
dogg
it was just it was it was a [ __ ] show
yeah so cat did you
did you watch you and stevie watched it
yeah we
uh watched the fight after the alpaca
farm
it was just one of those things where we
took a nap in between when we started to
realize that it was just a concert and
then
maybe we'd wake up and see a fight going
on and you guys saw the fight
yeah we saw the fight yeah it was
interesting
yeah something something there the many
people i'm so curious how many people
watched it
the problem now something you think
about too is those that jake paul
audience they're really internet savvy
so i would imagine over half of them
didn't pay for that thing
you can get stream streaming links and
they ain't like espn disney
with ufc like ufc is hard to stream i'm
pretty sure i bet
most kids watch that for free i'll tell
you right here did at least
one at least 1.45 million and then add
in the legal streams you i bet you're
talking
three to four million people watch that
at least yeah
yeah so think about this so it could be
two
two million and he gets a [ __ ]
share of the pay-per-view buys yeah so
he probably made you know
i bet five to six million
well look it's tommy fury he's calling
him out too he's calling he called out
tommy fury no tommy fury is calling out
uh
jake paul he won't fight tommy no no
there's no one coming for any
time he's not a big enough name b he's a
professional boxer
c he fights that light heavyweight like
yeah isn't dylan dana supposed to fight
jake paul next
that's what they're thinking i think it
could be mike perry who do you got on
that
uh i i would say that should be even
money
yeah that's a good fight mike perry's
ufc fighter
he's a dog he's a talker and he's known
for his striking too like oh okay
if he beats mike perry people are going
to have to give him some credit like
make perry's a knockout
now he's falling on hard times but he's
still he's like oh what that
that's like one of the worst nose
injuries you've ever seen in in fights
who did that to him uh who was it
somebody you don't know
oh god you know right yeah like i'm like
yeah hey who did that to him
and you're right yeah but can you bring
up his record yeah okay
where's he originally from new york how
did you get how do you get started
they're similar size too man
oh that he's the size of uh jake similar
yeah be good fight and he's he's no punk
like he has a chin
that'd be a good fight and i mean he's a
legit fight
i mean fighter with stand up that'd be a
next
nice step like dylan if i'm his manager
i go dillon down it's mike perry
this [ __ ] it's interesting though right
yeah is that jen that's it
all right all right kids uh this cruise
in austin texas this weekend thursday
friday saturday
late show at ooh you got it on the list
uh late show added this thursday
all shows are damn near sold out so we
added a late show thursday at 10
p.m at the vulcan gas company me and
this thick squad
and some special guests will be in
austin texas
this week let's keep austin thick and
then uh
just added literally a few minutes ago
lexington kentucky may 6th through the
8th
we're in kentucky baby probably drinking
some whiskey out there in kentucky
and then houston texas may 20th through
22nd get your tickets at
fatkz.com austin see you this thursday
friday saturday
we out then
sorry may 6 through the 8th i'll be in
philly
at the helium comedy club tickets at
chapellelacey.com
and then that following weekend may 13th
through the 15th
i'll be at good night's comedy club
tickets on sale
now but i'm excited for both of those uh
areas
actually people i've been hearing good
things carolina's dope yeah people were
saying dumb things about i already know
billy's one of the best clubs in the
nation yeah i already know philly's uh
and i'll set you up with my boys at
suplex oh yeah yeah you'll be set
oh yeah they already hit me up they got
tickets this year yeah they're gonna be
through yeah so that's gonna be a
problem
you're there when we're in kentucky yep
all right i know
and i love kentucky kentucky has my
heart i've never been there you've never
been kentucky
i've been everywhere i've never been in
kentucky literally i've been
everywhere are you doing that comedy off
broadway i have no clue
oh you don't you don't click on it chin
where am i at
they just tell me where to go these days
yeah
i think it's coming off broadway is that
the only event i think that's the one i
think that's the one
yep you're right call me off broadway
yeah i was right
there it is everybody likes that club
that's pretty fun really yeah
and then i can go on the whiskey tours
too yep the boys can be faded
probably better you don't come somebody
doing whiskey tours every day hey man do
your whiskey to her thanks man i'll i'll
i would just smell the [ __ ] you know
what i mean that's cool i like smelling
whiskey i know that was weird
this is weird my kids